well after the two people were killed on
London Bridge on Friday evening focus
has understandably shifted to why a
convicted terrorist was allowed out of
prison early the Prime Minister has
confirmed that 74 people jailed for
terror offences but released early will
now have their licence conditions
urgently reviewed Osman Khan's lawyer
Raja Hat's Sharif joins me now from
central London thanks very much for
being with us on Sky News sir this
afternoon when you heard the news that
one of your clients was responsible what
went through your mind
I was shocked it was quite unexpected
because immediately before his release
he hadn't there was no indication that
he still continued to hold any extremist
ideology or have that kind of mindset
how long ago before Friday do you speed
him my last contact with him was around
March February March this year and what
did you talk about in that conversation
a very brief conversation about the
licensing conditions nothing significant
what point was he making
he was just querying some of his
licensing conditions yeah what were they
exactly because we know that he had a
tag on what were the conditions
surrounding his release I'm not aware of
the entirety of his conditions but there
was issues about curfew and reporting
according to police stations and had you
been aware that he was due to attend
this conference obviously you snuck him
some months earlier so maybe it hadn't
been arraigned though no give me an idea
give me a sense of what sort of person
he was what was he like he was a very
young man when he was originally in
custody following charge he was 17 years
old he pleaded guilty when he was 19
years old
so effectively he's he matured into an
adult while in custody
he was released when he was 28 he will
he seemed to which he clearly regretted
his initial ideology and mindset he
rejected Islamic state and al-qaeda
ideology and the underlying thinking
that led to his conviction and when I
spoke to him in October November
immediately before his release that was
confirmed by him and he was looking
forward to being released so what on
earth went wrong well often when
offenders are released that terror
suspects are released they have some
engagement with the radicalizes or also
known as intervention providers to
ensure that there any potential
extremists mindset is addressed my point
is that this should start during the
custodial element of the sentence while
they're in custody before they're
released on licence so you're saying
that the rehabilitation that he should
have been getting in prison didn't
happen or wasn't good enough there was
some element of conventional probation
intervention however with ideological
offenders the situation is far more
complex as you'd appreciate there are
elements of political ideology which
addresses the extremist views but also
underlying Islamic theology and that is
an extremely specialist area and
specialists need to get involved during
the custodial element of the sentence
several I mean several years I feel
before the offender was released on
licence such that any concerns such as
the underlying ideology whether there
are any residual continuing extreme
views they can be addressed and also to
address the the safeguarding element for
the public and given that you spoke to
him not that long ago yes did did any
alarm bells ring
with you did you feel that you wanted to
speak to the authorities speak to people
who perhaps should have been in charge
of monitoring and say look I'm not happy
about this I'm afraid my conversations
were too brief and not of that nature we
know he was linked to the extremists
Anjem Choudary out of the Giroud as well
did he ever talk to you about that and
whether he's still identified with some
of their radical views no it was clear
he rejected those views yeah we know he
was a very good actor as well don't we
because he was on this rehabilitation
conference when he committed the
atrocity well this is a thing I think I
feel strongly that had there been a
private intervention during the latter
part of his custody which continued into
the licensing period perhaps this aspect
could have been involved this may not be
needed to have happened but whatever the
reason why it didn't happen I can't
answer that do you think he got an
inappropriate sentence should he have
stayed in prison longer well now you're
questioning the underlying legal system
the fact is that we have a very good
professional system which is highly
regarded throughout the world the
prosecution and defense robustly argue
their points before objective and
impartial judges with considerable
experience in my view he received the
correct sentence the initial sentence
perhaps which was successfully appealed
the appeal judges probably considered
the case I I think that it's wrong to
argue that he received the wrong
sentence I think perhaps the focus
should be placed more on understanding
the underlying ideology while he was
still in custody
we know the Ministry of Justice is
undertaking a review of 74 convicted
terrorists the licensing conditions of
them have you other clients who have
been convicted of terror fences who have
now been released
I've had several clients who have been
convicted of terror fences he'd been
sick
cessful II released into the community
who have been rehabilitated who have had
engagement with intervention providers D
radicalizes and their views have changed
so what went wrong in Kahn's case do you
think I mean you've touched on it
already but why didn't it work for him
when it worked for other clients of
yours I don't know what form of
intervention he received whether the
person or the group of individuals were
appropriately qualified to make the
point and I've said already that this is
a very highly specialized area the
Probation Service does an excellent job
they deal with conventional criminals
and they're able to examine the
underlying social and economic
conditions and perhaps address mental
health issues but the specialism
required in this case is such that it
can deal with extremist ideology and
Islamic theology which with respect to
the probation service they may not be
the appropriate resource to deal with
that or address those issues
we know the prevent strategy has been
pretty controversial or what do you make
of that where experts go in and try and
speak to young people before they go and
commit atrocities in some places I'm
aware it has been successful some
interventions have been successful but
then again it depends on the type of
intervention and timing of it their vote
that they have also been reported in
many cases where there's been a clear
misunderstanding and misidentification
and some distress has been caused to
those who being approached
there has been criticism online of
lawyers who defend terrorists yes what's
your response to that well this is a
fundamental fundamental rights that we
have the right to a fair trial and this
is one of the rights living in a free
and democratic society where an
individual who is charged with a very
serious
and has a right to be properly
represented he can put what he or she
can put forward whatever explanation or
defense they want and that explanation
is put to an impartial and objective
jewelry it is properly tested by the
prosecution if the explanation or
defense is found wanting the individual
is convicted and properly sentenced but
you need to have this critical
adversarial approach to get the right
answers our legal system
is commended throughout the world as
being both impartial and fair and a
model have you spoken to you
Karnes family at all what was his family
background his family his parents are
first-generation Pakistani migrants they
are decent respectable hard-working
people the brothers the siblings are all
working hard they're married they at the
time of the original offense they were
they were shocked they were shocked that
he was involved in something like this
and just finally how did he get into
this what went wrong in his life given
everything you've said about his family
that made him go down this route well
this specific incident I can't explain
I can't excuse his original offending
when he was 17 years old
related to his association with Al
Muhajiroun
and there was an element of influence or
you could say grooming by more senior
people who he was surrounded by